president Trump wished Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg well before
leaving for the g7 the High Court said
on Friday that Justice Ginsburg had just
completed three weeks of radiation
therapy for a cancerous tumor she is the
oldest member of the court at O'Keeffe
reports the tumour was detected on
justice Ginsburg's pancreas during a
routine blood test and a biopsy at the
end of July confirmed a localized
malignant tumor the Supreme Court said
that after a three week course of
radiation therapy at a New York Hospital
the Justice tolerated treatment well and
no further treatment is needed at this
time dr. David agus CBS News medical
contributor and cancer specialist said
aggressive surgery was not an option
given her age and frail condition the
treatment was someone limited to just
treating that lesion with radiation
therapy the hope is this will keep the
cancer at bay is there a chance this
could cure the disease no question about
it is it likely unfortunately not the 86
year old Ginsberg has battled cancer
before last December she had part of her
lung removed after cancer was discovered
forcing her to miss a court session for
the first time in 26 years a decade ago
she was treated for pancreatic cancer
Ginsburg's health is a perpetual concern
in Washington given the courts narrow
five to four conservative advantage but
she vows to serve as long as she's able
there was a senator I think it was after
the pancreatic cancer who announced with
great Glee that I was going to be dead
within six months that Senator whose
name I've forgotten is now himself dead
and I am very much alive the supreme
court reconvenes on the first Monday in
October and Justice Ginsburg has been
keeping a busy schedule on Thursday
night she was spotted on Broadway
attending a production of pool on Rouge
for CBS this morning Saturday at
O'Keeffe Washington